That sort of ends what I'm going to
tell you about the brain and
visual function right now.
It is a huge area of research,
as you can imagine.
It's, it's, it's really
fundamental to the human system.
As I said, somewhere around 30%
of our cortex is devoted to this.
We get insights from computation in
understanding what the brain does.
And sometimes we get
insights from brain and
neurophysiology to thinking
about the computation.
And it's one of the areas in which we
get some direct connection between what
you might think of as artificial
intelligence and natural intelligence.
It's one of the areas that
we've pushed furthest on that.
There's also work going on, for example,
in computational modeling of,
aud of hearing, audition right?
So to understand what goes on in the
human system versus artificial system.
And in the other senses things
are just getting started.
So haptics, how do you go from touch?
I can touch an object and
I can tell you about it's shape.
How do I do that?
How can I tell that a texture, oh
that's probably the skin of an orange?
All right,
its a computational problem, and
we'd like to get insight back and forth.
So, sensation in general and
on robotics side, motor control,
is trying to get a computational
model of what goes on in the brain.
All right, so that's really all I'm
going to tell you about the brain.
It is fascinating stuff and
even in the popular literature,
there's a lot of information
getting out there that I,
that I would deeply encourage
you to go take a look.
And I think you'll enjoy it.